nowadays it's easy to grow desensitized
to all the blood and guts of the horror
movie genre but even the biggest
cinematic thrill-seekers have to draw
the line every now and again on what
they can stomach seen on screen here are
some horror movies that had audiences
reaching for the barf bags or racing for
the exit sign The Hills Have Eyes
Alexandre Aja's remake of The Hills Have
Eyes about a group of desert dwelling
mutants was unsettling enough just based
on the characters physical deformities
alone so when a whole gang of the crazed
cretins started attacking one family in
gratuitously terrible ways it was simply
too much sending some theater patrons
sprinting away what made the film
especially difficult to endure was how
no one was safe from the clutches of
these creatures not even the dog or the
baby
Salo or the 120 days of sodom this 1975
pier paolo pasolini pics still finds its
way on almost every best/worst list of
the genre even decades after its release
it was an exceptionally graphic
depiction of the nightmarish scenario
that might unfold for a group of
children who'd been abducted by fascists
in war-torn Europe from mutilation to
the forced consumption of excrement the
most unimaginable Horrors were realized
in this commonly walked out of film the
film was inspired by some of the darkest
literary works of all time including
Dante's Divine Comedy and seems to
explore the depths of inhumanity
presented in the existentialist take on
the nature of human evil presented in
the Marquis de Sade's Justine despite
earning critical favour and timeless
relevance it's still incredibly hard to
sit through trouble every day not
everyone has a taste for cannibalism and
the massive lockout sin festival booing
that the Unrated 2001 horror drama
trouble every day by Claire Denis earned
his proof the movie introduces an
American couple honeymooning in Paris
but the husband is really on a mission
to track down the wife of a fellow
doctor he'd been obsessed with what he
finds when he locates the couple is that
the woman who's the object of his
obsession has a nasty habit of seducing
men and eating them living out her
darkest desires in explicit visual
detail the movie wasn't meant to be such
a seed emptier as Denis herself once
said I don't set out to shock that's not
my way of doing things I don't think
it's explicit in the cannibalism it is
how a kiss becomes a bite if you say so
lady and while we're on that subject
bite this gory flick is about the effect
of a bug bite gone very very wrong but
it was the audience that really got
infected when bike premiered at the
Fantasia International Film Festival
the pics producers were reportedly
prepared in advance for the rampant
upset stomachs that would follow the
screening and even passed out barf bags
to attendees but that didn't stop people
from exiting the flick early for those
who haven't braved the bomb inducing
experience it's about a bachelorette
whose celebratory trip to Costa Rica
goes way off course when she's bitten by
a bug that she thinks is harmless but
the infection turns her into a murderous
loon whose body slowly morphs into an
insect herself reviewers who pan the
film chided its illogical homage to
David Cronenberg's the fly but some
still found favor in director Chad
Archer bolts use of gruesome screen
tactics and almost everyone had to skip
a meal or two after viewing it whether
they liked the movie or not Caligula
this 1979 take on the Roman Emperor
who's a notorious sexual appetite and
penchant for cruelty marked his
tyrannical reign and prompted his
eventual assassination was so
exceedingly violent that even famed
reviewer Roger Ebert took leave of it
early his scathing review was so harsh
that he actually feared it might entice
audiences to check it out simply because
they quote simply cannot believe any
film could be this vile he went on
writing some of those people were
walking out of the theater before I did
others were sitting depressed in the
lobby Ebert's assessment was echoed by
many of his peers as the film was
consistently slammed by even those who
did manage to sit through its full
two-and-a-half hour runtime martyrs
Pascal August 2008 revenge horror flick
is widely regarded as one of the most
unsparingly violent movies ever made the
film which follows two young women on a
maniacal payback mission to hunt down
their former abusers featured several
scenes of extreme depravity and sent
many audience members packing along the
way the movie was wilfully provocative
and prompted revulsion even in viewers
with a relatively strong Constitution
Baskin this unrated Turkish fantasy
horror movie featured a group of police
officers who inadvertently waltzed
through a door to hell and left many
moviegoers heading right out the door to
the theater the McCobb movie was
relatively well received by critics who
savored all its devilish delights but
during its debut there were walkouts
galore Baskins writer director khan ever
knowledge
the last few minutes were a bit much for
them whether it was the nightmarish
blood baths or the philosophical
overtures of the demonic beans there
were plenty of disgusting moments to be
seen and fled from in this ghastly movie
probably not a great date movie probably
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]